we've had a lot of time with the
PlayStation hardware we've got it
figured out really well it's running in
brilliant 1080p 60 frames per second
it's going to be a great experience in
addition to playing plants vs zombies
garden walk around the big screen you
can also pay it on physician Peter or
any of you tablet with a playstation 2
cannula avid reader you could also try
the more plate where you can basically
get the same experience educating in the
pitching on to your Vita and I have two
more bility to move around hopefully I'm
Vita a lousy play the entire game on the
be anywhere you be that on the go or in
bed it's a really cool feature we're
really happy to bring a defense when
you've got the Vita it actually feels
really natural in the hand you've got
your own personal screen right there so
you're not playing on a smaller subset
of screen it's a really good positive
experience and it doesn't matter which
game oh and whether you're in co-op
whether you're in multiplayer you can
pick up the Vita and you can go into
boss mode and you'll other fly around in
crazy Dave's crazy RV or doctors or
losses flim another theorem we done
basically the same as PlayStation 4 you
basically get the same experience that
you were gonna go the big screen now on
your Vita
and it looks and feels as good as it
does on transition for again one of the
great things about the PlayStation is
there's a lot of content coming out
right away all the content that's been
released on all their other platforms is
going to be there day one we're very
very excited about it we think this is a
huge deal in addition we're going to
keep adding new content to the
PlayStation looking at new characters
new maps new customization new game
modes we love our game and we want to
continue to support our game and if our
new users engaged and having fun and
well into the future